como te darás cuenta otra vez tenemos el
mismo inicio de enunciado tenemos un
número primo impar esto es que 2 no es
ese primo itp es el conjunto de matrices
del tamaño 2 por 2 donde tenemos a en la
diagonal es el mismo número de acá
arriba y se acaba jo y estos tres
números son números enteros entre 0 y p
menos 1
ahora nos preguntan cuál es el número de
matrices a que están en este conjunto
tales que su determinante no es
divisible entre p entonces esto
realmente lo podemos continuar de los
dos ejercicios anteriores del ejercicio
42 y 43 como lo continuamos bueno en el
ejercicio lo lo que voy a hacer es lo
siguiente este es mi esquema que voy a
hacer voy a calcular el total de
elementos que hay en este conjunto de
matrices y después voy a restar todas
todas el número de matrices que sí
tienen determinante divisible entre p y
ya tengo un avance porque en el vídeo
anterior hicimos el número de matrices
cuyo
cuya traza no es divisible entre p ok
pero su determinante si lo es ahora
tengo que ver cuáles son aquellas cuyo
determinante es divisible pero su traza
también es divisible entre p y luego
sumo y eso me da el total de matrices
cuyo determinante es divisible entre p
luego se lo restó al total de elementos
de este conjunto y ya tengo las que no
son divisibles entre p entonces déjenme
déjenme escribir todas estas ideas tengo
el total el total de elementos
calcular el número de elementos de que
se encuentran en nuestro conjunto tp muy
bien y entonces cuántos elementos puede
tener bueno esencialmente tengo yo que
elegir a b y c de cuántas formas puedo
elegir a b y c a puede tomar valores
distintos 0 12 etcétera hasta t menos 1
entonces a tiene posibilidades b también
tiene posibilidades y se también
entonces esto simplemente se convierte
en multiplicar p por sí mismo 3 veces
que es p al cubo este es el número total
de elementos en este conjunto ahora bien
en el en el vídeo del problema número 43
que que es el vídeo anterior calculamos
el número de matrices as
el número de digamos de as verdad tales
que tal es que la traza la traza de esta
matriz a no es divisible
es divisible entre p
/ p pero sí pero su determinante es
decir el determinante de a si lo es
sí lo es si era divisible entre p
entonces cuando cuando dijimos que la
traza no fuera divisible entre p si no
has visto el vídeo anterior te aconsejo
que lo veas antes ok el número de
matrices cuya traza no era divisible
entre p
bueno esta condición de que la traza no
sea divisible entre p se convierte
simplemente en pedir que el elemento a
no sea 0 sólo podría ser 0 el caso en
que la traza fuera divisible entre p
entonces pedíamos que a no fuera 0 y de
hecho el número de elementos de este de
este digamos que cumplen esta condición
eran de menos 1 al cuadrado muy bien
entonces estos esto es el caso en el que
a es distinto de 0 qué pasa si ahora a
es igual a 0
qué pasa si ya es igual a cero si nos
damos cuenta voy a buscar el caso en que
el determinante sea divisible entre p
cuando a es cero
de esta forma voy a obtener
de matrices que cuyo determinante es
divisible entre p entonces vamos a ver
quién sería el determinante de a quién
sería el determinante de a esto es por
definición es éste por este que está
cuadrada menos este por este que es de
por sí muy bien pero en este caso
dijimos que hay cero entonces esto no
pinta y simplemente nos queda menos b
por c y estamos esperando que su
determinante sea múltiplo de p es decir
sea un número entero k por p donde cada
por supuesto puede ser positivo o
negativo puede ser cero ahora bien
vamos a ver qué pasa el primer caso es
por ejemplo que este múltiplo sea 0
entonces tenemos menos veces igual a
cero la pregunta es bajo qué condiciones
menos veces igual a cero o lo que es lo
mismo veces es igual a cero muy bien que
sea esa es una condición
otra condición puede ser que menos b por
c sea igual a menos pero de hecho
de hecho si nos damos cuenta a veces son
números digamos mayores o iguales que 0
así que el producto de ellos es mayor o
igual que 0 pero con el menos se vuelve
menor o igual que 0 entonces este
múltiplo debe ser menor o igual que 0
así que el primero de ellos puede ser
menos p muy bien entonces si nos damos
cuenta esto es esto no puede ser porque
quiere decir que veces es igual a p lo
que es lo mismo decir que p tiene una
descomposición en un producto de dos
números pero p es un número primo hay
que recordar que
es un número primo y su única
descomposición es decir los únicos
divisores de p es uno y sí mismo que es
p pero ninguno ninguno puede ser p
porque dijimos que son menores que p a
lo más pueden ser p - uno entonces este
caso no puede ser este caso no puede ser
y solo nos vamos a quedar con este de
acá porque tampoco puede ser que menos
veces sea igual a menos 2 p y es un
argumento similar verdad es un argumento
similar porque veces sería 2 p o lo que
es lo mismo veces entre 2 es igual a p
entonces p es otra vez un producto de
dos números pero esto no es posible muy
bien entonces
no es posible porque bueno me tendría
que ser 1 y se tendría que ser divisible
entre 2 muy bien entonces se tendría que
entre 2 tendría que ser p pero p no es
divisible entre 2 y ya con eso quitamos
este argumento y cualquier múltiplo de
negativo de p entonces sólo nos vamos a
quedar con este caso y vamos a ver vamos
a calcular cuántos post cuántas
posibilidades tenemos entonces si ven
por 6-0 quiere decir que por ejemplo b
es igual a 0 y se también es igual a 0
ahora puede que sólo uno de ellos sea
cero verdad el producto de dos números
de cero siempre que al menos uno de
ellos sea cero entonces qué pasa si b es
igual a cero pero que se no es cero
no es cero cuántas posibilidades tenemos
aquí bueno bella sabemos que no perdón
que es cero ya contamos el caso en que
se es igual a cero entonces se puede
tomar cualquier otro valor que no sea
cero y tenemos justo p - son valores
entonces aquí tenemos p - son
posibilidades ahora bien de forma
idéntica qué pasa si si se es igual a 0
y b no es 0 es exactamente el mismo
argumento vamos a tener p - 1 el p - son
posibilidades muy bien entonces qué es
lo que tenemos al final tengo aquí una
posibilidad y luego p - 1 y p - 1
entonces tengo p menos uno más
p menos uno más uno verdad este uno de
aquí entonces tenemos p - 1 - 1 esto es
2 p menos 1 y menos 1 es menos 2 más 1
21 esto es 2 p - 1 este es el número de
posibilidades que tenemos para que las
matrices sean divisibles entre p y a lo
mejor tú dices ah ya ya casi acabamos
verdad pero hay que hay que sumarle
estas si te das cuenta tenemos aquí el
número de matrices cuyo determinante es
divisible entre p pero la traza no es
divisible entre p acá tenemos las
matrices cuya traza es divisible entre p
es decir que es 0 y su determinante
también lo es si sumamos estos dos
entonces ya tenemos todas las matrices
cuyo determinante es divisible entre p
entonces si sumamos esto de aquí es de
cuadrada menos 2 p - 2 p más 1 y estoy
aquí hay que sumar más 2 p menos 1
entonces este se cancela este también y
simplemente me quedo p cuadrada esto es
de cuadrada posibilidades
posibilidades
de as de matrices as
cuyo determinante cuyo determinante
determinante
aunque cuyo determinante es divisible
entre p divisible entre p muy bien ahora
quizás tú dirías bueno ya acabamos pero
todavía no estas son las que son
divisibles su determinante entre p yo
quiero las que no son divisibles así que
al total le restamos las que sí son
divisibles y nos da las que no son
divisibles cuantas teníamos en total
dijimos que eran p al cubo y le restamos
las que son divisibles cuyo más bien su
determinante es divisible y espe
cuadrada así que ahora sí este es el
número de matrices as
tales que tales que el determinante de a
no es divisible no es divisible entre p
entre p y con esto ya estaríamos
acabando el problema si lo hicimos muy
bien si lo hicimos bien y si lo hicimos
bien porque aquí está la respuesta de de
que resuelve este problema son p al cubo
menos p cuadrada y es la opción d